uh you wrote some letter dude a letter
from comedian mark norman uh and it was
entitled by the way this was published
this month march 1st i don't know if
this was an april fools joke it was
called one comic's journey oh the
whalebone magazine what is this letter
what is this uh what is this uh this
magazine did a comedy issue yeah and uh
i know the guy who uh publishes the
magazine he said hey can you write
something and i said i don't know what
to write he goes just tell me about how
you got started yeah i just wrote this
thing on a plane in my phone real quick
and i texted it to him well dude it's
freaking awesome oh i'm just kidding i'm
not it's like it's probably you know
half a page i'm not gonna do the whole
thing i'm not gonna you know it's long i
could have you read it but then you
would probably be out but i'm gonna read
it yeah but basically it's basically
saying hey hey hey mark norman here new
york city stand-up comedian right yeah
that's a nice thing mark
don't want to hear mine
basically you're talking about how you
moved to the big city uh from new
orleans and you came to new york city
with 800 bucks in your pocket in a dream
yada yada yada yada you lived in a
shoebox you you did uh you got mugged
three times and it was a good uh hour
plus commute from uh into manhattan from
work you talked about that
right
uh going through all the the trials and
tribulations of new york stand-up comedy
we're getting to the point here amber
um
you said you know people have said to me
did you ever want to quit or move back
and get a real gig and you said honestly
i never even thought about it
so um you know you said the thoughts of
you know sitting in a cubicle chasing
some invisible stability that doesn't
exist whatever [ __ ] or they teach
you in school just wasn't for you right
so trying to break into the comedy world
is lousy with hardships and obstacles
but until you go through it you can
never feel the insane varieties of
rejection shame and humiliation
bombing
is the one thing
is one thing but being booed begging
people on the sidewalk to be your
audience and getting stiffed by club
owners and the list goes on
right so you're saying i got a lot of
these newbies asking to pick my brain
yeah or go out to coffee but uh there's
really just a waste of freaking time you
say time could be better spent
writing new jokes or soaking up stage
time there's no shortcut go get better
and then you go on to say um
this is sort of like uh life advice here
right uh-oh this is where you're gonna
get real uncomfortable right now but i
respect it bro you said
you know all that all the stuff that the
challenges you deal with that's
basically you know that's what life is
pushing up pushing the ball up the hill
uh so and then to quote you well i'm not
quoting you this whole time but then yes
this part is in quotes it says take
breaks be grateful enjoy what you've
accomplished but still but you still
have to keep
creating
success has its flaws and hiccups but i
don't know too many people who'd go back
keep going folks
and be nice yeah so
there you are bro does that kind of sum
up who you are give us give us take us
out here i should take my own advice you
know we all want more we're all all
unhappy we're all chasing something we
all got childhood trauma um but
you know we're lucky to be alive uh
things could be worse we could be in a
war we could be in ukraine we could be
back in this pandemic uh so
remember everybody's going through
something it's not just you and uh
be grateful for what you got and and
work for more don't just expect more
earn it and uh kim kardashian said that
and uh
[ __ ] her before pete davidson no no
but yeah just uh everybody's is a mad
about what they don't have like like
nobody wants to work anymore we notice
that like i shouldn't have a job and i
should get money for free and all that
and i think that is exciting and nice
but i think if people worked more they
would actually be happier
i think it's the opposite we're going
the opposite route that we should be and
look how upset everybody is look how
much how volatile everyone is how on
edge everyone is so i say
find something you love and and work at
it and get good at it and stop expecting
so much and start giving more
queef it up praise allah i'll see you
all in hell i'm gay thanks a lot
i've been kevin hart right yeah i'm
kevin that's awesome well i'll give you
a compliment bro and then we'll sign out
on amber before i want to get your
thoughts on this you're actually exactly
what i thought you'd be you're great
brother how do you like that i i mean
i've watched because i used to do comedy
and i watch a lot of comedy you can just
kind of tell who people are for the most
part if you turned out to be a massive
douche by what i didn't see that one
coming right but i expected so respect
to you bro thank you for being here
amber your final thoughts on today's
episode with mark norman i just meant
you're not socially awkward and you
claim to be and you just wow i can't
make eye contact too well i feel like
we're doing okay with that i don't know
i think everybody just locked eyes for
like thank
i appreciate when you can have uh great
intellectual conversations with
comedians that it doesn't feel the
pressure of being punchline every single
second and it takes takes over the
points that you're making so i
appreciate it yeah well
maybe maybe a reason uh that you're
you're doing so well blown up is you
know when you know one door closes one
door opens you know rest in peace nor
mcdonald yeah she kind of thinks that
you're the kind of the next norm and
that's not a bad thing at all bro i
should tell you i have cancer
[Laughter]
and i will say that you're naturally
hilarious bro it's not an act and it's
not funny i mean it's uh it's not forced
it's not fun
uh but respect for telling us about
pretty much everything that's going on
in your life get back on the two
where can everyone find you give us a
little sign up
marknormancomedy.com for dates tuesdays
and stories we might be drunk out to
lunch netflix the stand-ups and uh yeah
say hello
buy a shirt how about a hug and try not
to heckle and sorry but i've been
farting
[Music]